I had a playdate with my BFF Mike got
murky with some episodes and I showed on
him a recog zwei she should never have
me on her podcast I know I know general
I'm getting to it
mooch do I really have to go now that I
love is so new I'm sorry but Kelly says
you got a for real this time at least
now I can go see my wife and newborn son
[Laughter]
I'm not going to do that but there is
one more thing before I go
is it all the time expression you know
what it is I know baby
[Applause]
take him away
viral I Love You mr. president where I
love you I love we love you I love you
know what I'll make you mr. president
I'll miss you with you there I'll miss
you most of all look he's trying to do
it right and you'll never make it you
there we go back to compose a on that's
the way I like it